the u.s isn't the only country dealing
with a vaccine shortage the competition
to secure doses
is now threatening to create conflict in
europe
and with the developing world charlie
dagetta is following this
in london charlie what are we seeing
there well michelle we knew
the race for vaccines would be
competitive but now it's getting ugly a
dispute between the eu and the uk
threatens supplies here while world
leaders accuse rich nations
of nationalism and hoarding
the nighttime curfew that sparked
rioting this week in the netherlands was
just one of the more
aggressive measures taken to stem the
runaway variant of the virus
first identified in the uk where a grim
face
prime minister boris johnson announced
the country had become the first in
europe
to surpass 100 000 deaths on this day i
should just
really repeat that i am deeply sorry for
every
life that has been lost the scramble for
vaccinations has never been more
critical and
tension's never higher after
british-based astrazeneca said there
would be around a 50 million dose
shortfall in promised eu
supplies the eu threatened to impose
export limits on the pfizer biontech
vaccine
manufactured in belgium some destined
for britain
the european union will take any action
required
to protect its citizens and rights
the eu demanding vaccine companies
provide early notification before
exporting to third countries
raising the possibility of holding back
supplies for themselves
addressing the world economic forum in
davos south african president cyril
ramaphosa
lashed out at vaccine nationalism now
rich countries in the world are holding
on to these vaccines and we are saying
release the excess vaccines
that you have you have ordered and and
hold it
as numbers of cases and deaths continue
to climb
vaccine embargoes only threaten to
worsen the global
pandemic now let's put those numbers in
perspective it took 11
months for the world to reach 50 million
cases just three months for that number
to double
to a hundred million cases vlad that's
an eye-opening statistic charlie dagen
and london as always
we thank you